he was the child from hell born into
royalty with the deformity that put a
lifelong chip on his shoulder but by the
time it became ruler of Germany this
grandson of Queen Victoria had grown to
hate the British
hate the French and well-paid just about
every other European power over the next
20 years he orchestrated the tension
that exploded into the nightmare that
was world war one and in this week's by
graphics we uncover the mixed on life of
Kaiser Wilhelm the second
the child who was to become kaiser
wilhelm ii was born Friedrich Wilhelm
Victor Albert von Hohenzollern the date
was January the 27th 1859 and the place
was Potsdam in what was then the state
of Prussia his father was Prince
Frederick Vilhelm of Prussia while his
mother was the English Princess Victoria
the birth was not an easy one with the
doctor having great difficulty getting
the baby out of the birth canal as a
result vill Helms left arm was virtually
useless being significantly shorter than
his other arm many historians believe
that vil hems deformity stunted his
emotional growth and contributed to his
reckless behavior in later life what is
certain is that he was extremely
self-conscious about his impaired arm
and constantly sought ways to hide the
deformity
vilhelm was second in line to be the
King of Prussia he was also the first
grandson born to England's Queen
Victoria Victoria was fond of the child
considering to be a well-mannered young
step from the start however he
demonstrated a volatile disposition at
the age of four he was taken to England
to attend a royal wedding part of his
tiny uniform included a small dagger
during the ceremony Vilhelm began
fidgeting his uncle's standing alongside
nudged him and told him to be still but
the very four-year-old he was having
none of this he pulled out the dagger
and threatened to stab his uncle then
when the uncle attempted to restrain him
Vilhelm bitten in the leg grandmother
Victoria would not have been amused but
fortunately she never found out about
the incident though AIIMS mother was
constantly worrying about her son in
addition to having to contend with his
angry manner she felt guilty about his
arm deformity irrationally blaming
herself for the condition she worried
that it would prevent him from
fulfilling his obligations as heir to
the throne one thing she was determined
not to let the arm deformity do was
stopped her son from riding a horse as a
result she ensured that he began taking
horse riding lessons at the age of eight
the lessons were hell for the future
ruler he constantly fell from the horse
largely due to the lack of balance
caused by his deformed arm yes after
weeks of persevering often with tears
rolling down his cheeks he managed to
overcome his limitations becoming a
capable horseman in 1871 the German
Empire officially came into being
it was to be ruled by the King of
Prussia twelve-year-old vilhelm was now
second in line to become the head of two
nations in his preteen years Phil Homme
had been privately tutored from the age
of 13 however he was sent to the
Friedreich's gymnasium in Castle he
proved to be a talented students
performing well in all of his studies he
graduated at the age of 18 in 1877
grandmother Victoria was sent delighted
with her special boy that she awarded
him the Order of the Garter one of the
highest that she could have bestowed
upon him after graduating he attended
the University of Bonn for the next four
years he studied law and politics in
addition to his formal studies vilhelm
was inculcated into the military ideals
of Prussian manliness this concept of
the tough disciplines military men was
closely aligned with that of Prussian
nationalism although his mother tried
hard to impress the Victorian ideals of
liberalism upon him
Wilhelm shuns them in favor of the
Prussian way villains military service
began at the age of 21 he was given the
rank of first lieutenant in the first
regiment of foot guards based in Potsdam
he took to army life like a duck to
water he later said the following about
his time in the military I really found
my family my friends and my interests
everything of which I up to that time
had to do without above all his time in
the military imbued the young prince
with self-confidence he became sure in
his bearing and he began to speak with
an air of authority however the more he
developed as a military man the more
distant he became from his parents if
you'd them as being too invested in
British liberalism at the expense of
Prussian nationalism Wilhelm was 21 when
he met his future wife August a Victoria
of schleswig-holstein she was also known
as Donna it wasn't his first foray of
the heart a couple of years before he
had fallen hard for his first cousin
Princess Elizabeth of hesse-darmstadt
but she had refused his marriage
proposal not so with Donna and the
couple got engaged in 1880 they were
married in 1881 and they'd go on to have
seven children following his marriage
Vilhelm gains a powerful ally in the
form of Prussian statesman Otto von
Bismarck who saw the princes and means
of advancing his own political career he
would use the boy as a
means of gaining an advantage over their
parents with Bismarck pulling strings
Vilhelm began to be sent on diplomatic
missions the first was to sim Petersburg
to attend a coming-of-age ceremony for
sixteen-year-old Tsarevich Nicholas
but the haughty and arrogant Vilhelm did
not make a favorable impression on Tsar
Alexander two years later in 1886 vilem
went with his grandfather to visit the
austrian-hungarian Emperor Franz Josef
this trip went better largely because
Vilhelm was under the ever watchful eye
of his grandfather kaiser wilhelm the
first
[Music]
meanwhile Bismarck worked it's preparing
Vilhelm for rulership he encouraged him
to view all things English with disdain
and to reject the worldview of his
parents then not March the 9th 1888
Kaiser Wilhelm the first died villa homs
father now inherited the role but just a
few months into his reign he succumbed
to throat cancer Vilhelm now became
kaiser wilhelm ii of prussia and germany
he was 29 years of age and the date was
June the 15th 1888 immediately upon
ascending the throne vilhelm came into
conflict with his advisors chief among
them was otto von Bismarck the
experienced statesman advocated a policy
of peaceful relations with the other
heads of state in Europe but vilhelm was
intent on extending the territorial
borders of Germany and was ready to
pursue an aggressive international stops
Bismarck had been the trusted foreign
adviser to Kaiser Wilhelm the first but
the new Kaiser had no such trust for the
statesman for his part Bismarck thought
once Vilhelm ascended to the throne that
he would be able to manipulate and
control him he soon realized that had
been very wrong fill homes tolerance for
Bismarck reached its limit when the old
man tried to implement an anti socialist
policy Vilhelm opposed the policy as
every opportunity eventually the two had
a heated encounter which ended with
Vilhelm demanding Bismarck's resignation
[Music]
with MS marques Foreign Minister a
balanced state of peace existed between
Germany France and Russia the Russians
they now had no confidence in Phil
Holmes ability to maintain the peace and
so they grew closer with France the
peace between Russia and Germany began
to grow increasingly fragile
in the early 1900's vilhelm focused on
building up Germany's Navy he saw a
powerful Navy as being a symbol of
Germans position as a world superpower
and he became obsessed with the idea of
huge ships many hours were spent drawing
his own designs of ships he also made
sure to let the rest of Europe know how
he was building up his nations military
might at the same time that he was
stretching his international muscles
vilhelm was making domestic improvements
he reformed public education to make it
available to every child he was also an
advocate of the arts and sciences
starting the Kaiser Wilhelm Society to
advance scientific research Phil Ham
heard by now managed to alienate most of
the leaders of Europe he was lacking in
patience he had an explosive temper and
possessed no tact whatsoever an infamous
example of his ability to alienate
others was when in 1896 he sent a
telegram to president Kruger of the
Transvaal Republic in South Africa the
message congratulated Kruger for his
suppression of the British led Jamestown
rate when news of the telegram reached
Britain it caused an outcry of rage
against Germany even before this
incident even those in the British royal
family who were related to Vilhelm they
didn't like him in addition to his
natural arrogance his over racism
alienated others he constantly warned
European leaders of the Yellow Peril
referring to Japan and China
while he was content to alienate the
European powers vilhelm went out of his
way to develop cordial relations with
the leaders of the Ottoman Empire his
first trip to Istanbul was in 1889 he
made a deal to sell guns to the Ottoman
army nine years later he undertook a
month-long trip through the Holy Land
before heading home he professed his
undying friendship for the tax in 1905
ville home committed one of his biggest
diplomatic blunders when he visited
Tangier in Morocco there he met with
representatives of Sultan Abdul Aziz
expressing his support for Moroccan
sovereignty this was a direct challenge
to the French who had a large military
presence in Morocco it also further
alienated the Kaiser from the
international community what became
known as the Moroccan crisis also served
to bring previous a lifelong rivals
France and Britain closer together in
their opposition to the aggressive
stance of the German ruler in 1908
vilhelm agreed to an interview for the
British newspaper The Daily Telegraph
seeing it as an opportunity to
strengthen anglo-german relations during
the interview his fiery temper got the
better of him and he managed to insult
the British people numerous times as
well as insinuating that the Russians
and French had tried to pull Germany
into the second bar war the whole
interview it was a disaster and it
greatly embarrassed the German people
goals were even made for Vilhelm to
abdicate in the wake of the fallout from
the interview Vilhelm laid low after a
month he emerged did he immediately
forced his Chancellor Prince Bulow to
resign blaming him for authorizing the
disastrous interview in the first place
this was a terrible movement it lost him
a lot of the internal support that he
had remaining
this episode stole away any of the
self-confidence that vilhelm still had
he fell into a deep state of depression
all of his energy was thrown into his
pet project of building up the German
Navy his obsession with building more
powerful battleships than the British
got his country into serious financial
hardship by the beginning of 1914
vilhelm had managed to alienate all of
the major powers in Europe undoing all
of the work that Bismarck had done when
Vilhelm the first was Kaiser one of the
few friends that he had was Ferdinand
the Archduke of Austria the
assassination of 3rd and ends on June
the 28th 1914 deeply affected vilhelm
when it was revealed that an underground
movement called the black hand was
behind the murder he extended his full
support in hunting them down he also
urged austria-hungary to use force
against Serbia implying that he would
back them up
egged on by vilhelm franz joseph the
first of austria made demands of serbia
that were impossible to meet when the
deadline to meet the conditions passed
without satisfaction Austria declared
war on Serbia in response to this
Russian troops began to mobilize in
order to defend Serbia from attack
Wilhelm learns of the Russian
mobilization on July the 30th he knew
that his treaty obligations with Austria
meant that he was bound to declare war
on Russia
he was also convinced that England and
Russia and France had conspired to knock
out Germany this meant that he would be
faced with attack from two fronts the
Russians from the east and the British
and French from the West
back in 1905 a prominent German general
by the name of von Schlieffen had
devised a plan of attack on France now
the generals nephew Helmuth von Moltke
adapted the plan to fight a two-front
war the clan called for a preemptive
strike on the weaker country that week
account REE it was France once that
attack had been successfully carried out
the focus could then switch to Russia
Vilhelm he was sold on the plan but his
generals not so much they were convinced
that Russia was not prepared for war and
wanted to strike to the east first the
reality was the Russians were indeed
ready and had their army mobilized to
defend the Serbians
vilhelm got his way then the Schlieffen
Plan was put into action however it
proved to be a disaster as the German
war effort lurched on Ville Homs
influence became less and less as
Germany's top military officials Field
Marshal paul von hindenburg and general
Erich Ludendorff took the reins the
Kaiser busied himself with awarding
medals and officiating at military
ceremonies his moods followed a
manic-depressive pattern fluctuating
between euphoria that Germany was about
to crush the Allies and despair that all
was lost as the war drew to a conclusion
in the closing months of 1918 u.s.
President Woodrow Wilson announced that
the German Kaiser would not be permitted
to take part in any peace negotiations
this effectively made Vilhelm a
lame-duck leader
[Music]
as German capitulation drew ever nearer
a revolt broke out in Germany the vast
majority of people they were just sick
and tired of this bungling arrogant
leader there were calls for his
abdication still fill him vacillated
even without any support at all he
thought that he could retain at least
one or even two of us crowns but the
Constitution had stipulated that the two
crowns were to be forever intertwined
abdication from one throne meant
abdication from both of them
Oh November the ninth Chancellor Prince
Max von Baden announced that vilhelm was
abdicating he did this in order to stem
the tide of revolution but the
Chancellor's efforts they backfired and
he himself was forced to resign however
the next day November the 10th vilhelm
fled to the Netherlands at this time he
had still not abdicate it over the next
weeks however his top military advisor
paul von hindenburg advised an
abdication the general made it clear
that Vilhelm did not enjoy the support
of the army and they would not back him
when they returned from the war
realizing that the situation was
untenable Vilhelm faced reality and
abdicated on November the 28th 1918 the
Treaty of Versailles which officially
ended the war was signed on June the
28th 1919 in branded Kaiser Wilhelm is a
war criminal and stipulated that he be
prosecuted for a supreme offence against
international morality and the sanctity
of treaties the Netherlands governments
however they refused to extradite
Vilhelm the situation was actually
pleasing to President Wilson who felt
that the trial and prosecution of the
Kaiser would only prolong tensions
between Germany in the rest of Europe
the best thing would just be for vilhelm
to remain in the Netherlands
[Music]
velcome purchased a house in the
municipality of dawn he would remain
there for the rest of his life
the new German vimar Republic allowed
him to transport some of his possessions
there from his old palace in at Potsdam
he now made it his life's mission to
clear his name of wrongdoing and it came
to the war in April 19-21 villains wife
Donna she died a few months earlier
their son had committed suicide these
deaths were devastating blow to the
exiled Kaiser in 1922 William wrote a
memoir in which he defended his
international policy and put forth his
case that he was not responsible for a
war that had led to 10 million deaths at
the same time he became socially active
in the Netherlands entertaining
high-profile guests and engaging his
passions for archaeology and hunting he
also started a new hobby woodchopping
despite his withered arm he became quite
proficient at it chopping down thousands
of trees during the last two decades of
his life in mid 1922 bill Hamlet
Princess harmine Roose of Greece there
was an immediate mutual attraction and
they were married on November the 9th
[Music]
during the 1930s Vilhelm paid close
attention to the rise of Nazism he never
embraced the party or its leader but did
hold out hope that Hitler would
eventually restore the monarchy
it was his vain hope that his oldest
grandson would be appointed as Kaiser
once that occurred his wife I mean even
sent a request to that effect out of
Hitler but the Fuhrer he wasn't
interested in facts he felt a special
hatred for vilhelm blaming him for the
disastrous defeat in the First World War
as hell as actions became more extreme
the former leader of Germany observing
from his exiled home in the Netherlands
became increasingly alarmed at what was
taking place under Nazi rule when he had
heard that Hitler ordered the murder of
the wife of a chancellor he commented we
have ceased to live under the rule of
law and everyone must be prepared for
the possibility that the Nazis will push
their way in and put them up against a
wall the villa helms antipathy towards
Hitler became personal he believed that
the Fuehrer was turning his cherished
military into a gang of thugs
however as Hitler began a tract of
international military victories vilhelm
changed his tune and began to praise
upon him when the Netherlands were
occupied in May of 1940 here
received the following message from
vilhelm my Fuhrer I congratulate you and
hope that under your marvelous
leadership the German monarchy will be
restored completely Hitler wasn't amused
in fact he referred to vilhelm as an
idiot that impression was reinforced
when following the fall of Paris he
received this message congratulations
you have won using my troops under the
German occupation villains house was
kept under German guard this was more
there to provide protection for the old
Kaiser who was now 82 than to imprison
him it was done at the behest of a Nazi
general and when Hitler found out about
it he was furious and had the general
fired
guys of Elohim the second died on June
the 4th 1941 of a pulmonary embolism in
the death out of Hitler saw an
opportunity to make political capital he
ordered that the body be returned to
Berlin for a state funeral he saw this
as a way of showing to the German people
that the Third Reich was just a
continuation of the old German Empire
but
Hitler's wishes they were denied Vilhelm
had made it clear to the Dutch
authorities that he would never return
to Germany until the monarchy was
restored the Dutch government acceded to
these wishes and the body remained in
the Netherlands where it was given a
military funeral he was buried in a
mausoleum on the property of dawn that
was his Dutch home there it remains to
this very day so I really hope you found
my video interesting if you did please
do hit that thumbs up button below and
don't forget to subscribe brand new
videos several times a week and if you
want something else that's a bit
different indeed it's not actually a
youtube channel I do a podcast called
the brain food show if you just search
brain food one word in iTunes you'll
find it go give it a listen and let me
know what you think and as always thank
you for watching
[Music]